[Music]
but this morning las vegas realtors
released new numbers on our housing
market
home prices reached record highs last
month despite the pandemic
so if you've been thinking about selling
your home now might be the best time to
maximize your profit
hector mejia is live right now to break
down the state of our real estate hector
good afternoon
good afternoon we're told it's
definitely a seller's market right now
we are told the high home prices are due
to inventory being so low
and here at this local office berkshire
hathaway one realtor there tells us
it's still a good time to buy a home
though february's home
housing report rather from las vegas
realtors says the median price for a
home sold in town last month
was 355 000 that breaks the all-time
high that was set back in november
and up 12.3 percent from february of
2020
the median price for a condo or a
townhome topped 197
000 that's up thirteen percent from the
same time last year
we're hearing about bidding wars
happening left and right we talked with
a couple that said
they've been watching this play out in
real time they're out of state buyers
moving to las vegas from michigan it's
an emotional roller coaster
i mean one minute you got okay good
here's the house
that's the hard part is finding the
house that fits your needs
you put in a bid on it and then you wait
to hear back
and then there's another offer so you
have to go higher or offer a better
incentive and then it goes back again
it's a seller's market however it is a
buyer's market
and for investors as well and i'll
explain to you why
the interest rates are all-time low in
30 years
so that makes it advantageous for
everyone
as far as the housing supply goes it
keeps shrinking lvi president aldo
martinez says the sales pace in february
equates to less than one month supply of
existing homes for sale
he says inventory will not have much
room to grow
until unemployment improves mortgage
companies are not able to qualify
buyers who don't have a job and when
people get back to work we are told
that will likely soften the real estate
market and
realtors are also pointing to the
vaccine saying
that will boost consumer confidence and
in the end improve the economy
reporting live hector mejia 8 news now